Speaker 1: . We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two.
David P. Here is a voicemail I got from someone
brutally calling me out for things they maybe
misunderstood.
Let's take a listen.
Speaker 5: David, I'm a member.
This is Tim from California.
I'm outraged because you said that plumbers
make forty thousand per year.
No, I like I don't I think they make like,
one hundred thousand.
Speaker 1: No, no, no, no, no.
So what I. I referenced Joe the Plumber.
Joe the Plumber was known for during the 2008
election between Barack Obama and the late
Senator John McCain coming out and saying
plumbers like me are going to end up paying
a lot more in taxes under Barack Obama's plan.
And framed in that was the idea that he had
a plumbing business from which he made 250000
dollars a year, because if he didn't make
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars a year,
he wasn't going to pay any more.
Under Barack Obama's plan.
We later found out he didn't even own that.
He was like thinking of buying the plumbing
business or something like that, and he made
far less money.
So I didn't mean to suggest plumbers make
40 grand.
When I specifically said Joe the Plumber,
the point was he didn't make two hundred and
fifty thousand.
He wasn't going to be subject to more tax
under Obama and he wouldn't be subject to
more tax under under Joe Biden.
That was the point.
Let's continue.
Speaker 5: And that's according to Google,
too.
And Bill Nye isn't a scientist.
He's technically a mechanical engineer and
actor.
And I mean, I love Bill Nye, but he shouldn't
be called a scientist technically.
Speaker 1: When did I last even mentioned
Bill Nye?
I don't even know why someone's coming to
me with Bill.
Did I mention Bill Nye and just forget, it's
very strange, in any case, you can call the
voicemail number anytime you want to, a nine
to David Pakman.
I prefer that you comment on things I've actually
said very often.
The right wing trolls call in and attack me
brutally for things they must have heard on
some other show, because they're certainly
not things I talked about.
I don't know, but two one nine two David Pakman
is that number.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
The ACLU is facing a sort of identity crisis.
It was at one point simply known as the bastion
of free speech.
But the ACLU has been in some weird situations
lately.
I have a personal story to mention about this
that I'll tell you guys about.
That's on today's Bonas show.
California has approved a pilot program for
driverless vehicles, driverless rides, and
many people are excited.
Others are going completely crazy, as if the
sky were falling.
We will talk about that on today's Bonas show.
And also, the FDA has approved an obesity
drug that has helped some people drop a significant
amount of weight.
But there are some who believe that it is
not a fair drug, it is not a fair drug, because
it could allow people to have an unhealthy
lifestyle and diet and still lose weight.
And under the paradigm of strict father morality,
that would be wrong.
Very, very wrong.
So we'll talk about that on today's Bonas
show as well.
Get instant access to the bonus show by signing
up for a membership at Join Pakman Dotcom
or make a Patreon pledge at Patreon on dot
com slash David Pakman show.
I will speak to you that.